hello everyone
welcome to the active inference live
stream it is active inference live
stream
11.2 on december 29 2020. this is our
last group active inference live stream
of the year so thanks so much everyone
who is out here today
and also um watching live for those who
are
and i will share my screen for the
participants and here we go
welcome to the active inference lab
everyone we are an experiment in online
team communication
learning and practice related to active
inference you can find
us at our website on twitter email
youtube or our public key based team and
username
this is a recorded and an archived live
stream so please provide us with
feedback so that we can improve on our
work
all backgrounds and perspectives are
welcome here and as far as video
etiquette for live streams
mute if there's noise in your background
raise your hands so that we can hear
from everybody
on the queue and we'll use respectful
speech behavior
as i stated this is the last active
inference live stream for 2020
but in 2021 it's already shaping up to
be a great
year we're going to be meeting tuesdays
from 7 to 9 a.m
pacific time pst um or pacific time when
the time changes
and you can go to this link to learn
more when you go to that link you'll see
this spreadsheet and it has instructions
on how you can participate
as well as which papers we'll be reading
in which weeks
so you can see that many authors will be
joining us
and hopefully everybody will have the
time to read and digest these papers
today in active inference stream 11.2
we are going to have introductions and
warm-ups and then
we'll go into the 11-2 itself we're
going to be continuing
the discussion of sophisticated
affective inference
the paper of hesp at all 2020 welcome
sasha
we'll run through again the ames claims
abstract and roadmap
and the figures and happy new years
everyone thanks
a lot we'll do new stuff in 2021
and so stick along let's get to the
intros and warm-ups we will
introduce ourself just by giving a short
introduction or
check-in and then passing to somebody
who hasn't spoken yet
so i'll start i'm daniel and i will pass
it first to a first-time
visitor scott
hi i'm scott david i'm at the university
of washington applied physics lab and
i've been a lawyer for 27 years i'm
trying to use physics principles to help
structure social relationships and i
will pass it to
stephen
hello i'm stephen i'm based in toronto
i'm currently doing a practice-based phd
with canterbury christchurch university
and i'm looking at applying the dynamic
processes of active inference
into my work with participatory theatre
and community development
and helping to understand the dynamics
of all of that
and i will pass it to ivan
hello my name is ivana i am in moscow
and i am a researcher in system
management school
i'll pass it to blue
hello i'm blue knight i am an
independent research consultant
based out of new mexico and i will pass
it to
sasha
hi i'm sasha i'm based out of davis
california
and i study developmental neuroscience
and i will pass it to alex
hello my name is alex i'm in moscow
russia
i'm also researcher in systems
management school
and i'm trying to find the ways to
connect
active inference and systems engineering
framework
cool and ryan uh
it seems like has the same situation as
last week
but definitely for 2021 we'll
figure it out i'll just tell them it
still does not
work all right let's go to the warm up
questions and again if anyone else joins
we'll just
roll with it so for these warm-up
questions
raise your hand it'd be great to hear
from everybody let's just
start off with what are some kinds of
agents that we might want to model
in active inference so just even before
reading this paper or after reading the
paper what was the kind of system or
type of agent
that we might want to frame in this
way of thinking so emotions makes us
think about individual people
but there's other kinds of systems we
might want to model as well
actually scott you were mentioning some
interesting types of agents we might be
considering right before we started so
maybe could you pick up there
sure i was mentioning in law
it feels like one of the things one of
the strategies
is to introduce a provisional agent a
nominal party
into an interaction so if you have two
people interacting you can introduce a
third
by introducing the third it changes the
system because now a three-party system
with three-party concerns
and that system then will have a
different markov blanket as i
am beginning to understand it and so in
that
context you may be able to do things you
can't do in the other
through the other markov blanket because
it may be able to
an example is in in tax there's a thing
called the like kind exchange
where i can exchange commercial property
for another commercial property tax free
well very often you can't find someone
with exactly the property you're looking
for let's say you have a 20 acre farm
you want a 30 acre farm
there's nobody around with a 30 acre
farm you use an exchange facilitator and
that means there's a third party in
there they take possession of both
properties
and act like a mixing bowl and so
putting the details of that aside
it essentially changes that system so it
changes your markov blankets
and so one of the things i'm wondering
about is the intentional shifting of the
markov blankets
to increase solution space
cool so we have all kinds of agents who
are going to be
interacting and potentially by shifting
the boundaries
the interfaces between agents and
wrapping them or sub
partitioning them it's possible to make
new kinds of swaps
within existing infrastructures or new
ones
so anyone can just raise their hand i'll
just put up the second
question which is another general one
which is how can we learn
and communicate the technical aspects of
active inference in an accessible
fashion stephen go ahead i don't know if
i'm going to explain how to do this but
i'll explain the challenge which
um um i think it's important to
overcome it because it's so valuable is
i was just in a conversation
and trying to talk about systems and how
we can how we think about systems when
we
engage um in communities and thinking
about how we
understand the world there's a lot of
stuff in in the world of kind of the
social arts and participatory theater
where it's like
we need to do something with the system
and then it flips to
we're all a living system it's the body
knows and
we just know how it is we just need to
listen to the body and it will know
and um it's both you know it's
we're in this dynamic niche of which
there's an awful lot of stuff we don't
know
yet we can tap into our body
and the way that our body works and
there's
a way that we construct meaning in the
world so i suppose
trying to find a way to take case
studies
and show how it can help
will be really useful
thank you sasha
yeah um thanks steven i really um
i agree with what you said and uh
ironically or i guess in a very meta way
um active inference is the answer to
that question because
um through like closing the loop
and introducing action into the system
we can better
understand thinking about the system and
so i think that's a
really great point that um case studies
and
really specific applications of active
inference
are going to be the best way to teach
and learn
about it so yeah i think that's a great
point
cool blue so just to kind of piggyback
on that
i think um and maybe tie in some of what
scott was saying earlier
when we think about modeling in active
inference it's interesting to think
about
scaling this not in the way that we
talked about when we were talking about
scaling active inference but
in the way that like we have several
different systems even just existing
within the body
right like the input and output of the
stomach and the spleen and the liver and
and
you know also like the brain and the the
somatic awareness right to speak to kind
of what what stephen was saying earlier
so
it's interesting to try to think about
modeling systems within systems
in in active inference yep
and actually this brain and body uh
dialogue
and the multi-systems approach in the
way that it doesn't say well
everyone told you the brain was
important actually it's the body no it's
actually it's both and similarly it's
like quantitative
and qualitative and so it's not just
that we're going
to throw out one for the other but we
want to think
across that division and integrate them
that's the beyond internalism and
externalism and
integrating the sciences with the
humanities and other things that we're
kind of talking about
scott i just put in the chat there was
an article that came out
december 4th in science magazine called
the exploitative segregation of plant
roots
and so this is helps with that second
question
learn communicating it what it was
talking about is the way that plant
roots
grow specifically you have two trees
next to each other each is a system each
has a markov blanket
they're growing next to each other and
they differentiate their plant growth
roots to optimize statistically
their nutrient uptake and so they don't
go and intrude on other
plants roots space because that would
not be optimized for them because they'd
be putting more resources into growing
further roots
and and but getting fewer nutrients
because they'd be nearer the other plant
and so to me i looked at that and i went
wow that's a real nice way to understand
the
dynamics of two different organisms
interacting with statistical gradients
there it's a nutritional gradient
specifically that felt to me like it was
a nice way to kind of introduce that
idea of the of the contact between the
two different systems
cool so what i'm going to take from the
second question and all the answers to
it is that
through examples that are accessible and
at hand we can all start to
learn more about the relational side of
active inference and also
the statistical and the quantitative
because both those
sides are going to be learning journeys
for everybody because no one's going to
know all the statistics no one's going
to know all the
deep relational pieces that are so
familiar to performance artists in other
areas
the last question on the warm-up is what
is something that you are wondering
about or would like to have resolved by
today's discussion
so one thing i'm wondering about is um
was raised right before we started as
well is like how do we think about
emotion
or this parameter in systems that aren't
us
and i'm also even wondering whether the
emotions we experience
are these parameters and how do we name
parameters or talk about parameters of
mathematical models
in a way such that they're recognizable
and capture meaning
but also don't constrain or sort of
uh falsely limit what it means to be
that term
so we can get into a map territory issue
when we're talking about
computational models of emotion just
like we could with consciousness
blue
so just to kind of piggyback on what you
were saying about
um emotions like i i don't know as i'm
starting to study more about emotion
like i'm a
logic and science kind of researcher and
so but learning about emotion just
reading personally
a lot of it seems to be like non-verbal
right and so how do you like quantify or
even measure
emotion on a scale when it's it's really
like you know
you're feeling some you know primitive
thing from you know when you were
left in your crib as a child that you
have no words for because you didn't
have words for it at that time
and so how do you kind of like like
impart some kind of meaning or
quantitative scale
on something that that maybe there's not
even language for
yes it's almost like the uh discredited
but
guiding three-part brain model so it's
like the most
prefrontal is the numbers in that level
of formalization and then a little bit
lower we have language but then below
that the substrate is actually
experience and that's the embodied
experience
that may or may not even have words to
express it and then we can look at
expressions like poetry or speech
and is there a way to get more precise
or is it merely an expression that's
arising from an emotional state
but the emotional state isn't a number
it's not a words it's actually something
that's more
deep scott
i was wondering if with regard to dance
and performance
whether there are ways of communicating
because we talk about embodied i wonder
about in coding
so can emotions be encoded in dance in a
way that they can't be encoded in speech
or other movement
so that it becomes a surrogate or kind
of that mirror neuron idea
that you're projecting out an emotion by
the projection of your body position
the morphology being the encoding of the
emotion
cool question yeah stephen definitely
yeah i think this also relates to this
question of
um affect and dimensionality
so maybe there's a way that when we take
a perspective on things
we kind of look at a dimensional
approach but it can be encoded
in some sort of spatial um
affective way and maybe those dimensions
aren't
they they they become light dimensions
but the encoding is is not as
linear as that a bit like color space
when we see colors the space of colors
you can encode it
in sort of in in lightness and two
different types of coloured dimensions
but the way that it's encoded is
when people look at perception it's not
it's not linear in that space so maybe
there's like an
affect space which somehow encodes in a
in a way which is non-dimensional
so might oh sorry go ahead go so
my aesthetics be
provisional um efforts at encoding
very nice to bring in the aesthetics and
the intuition
because intuition is that which can't be
expressed it's sort of like the
dark matter it's the submerged part of
the iceberg
but those reflect the deepest priors
potentially
that help us search through the state
space that as we've been exploring
is vast to do the exponential rollout of
a chess game
is gonna be hard it's gonna be more um
basically states than you can keep track
of however
if you think i feel good about this uh
arrangement of the pieces
then with just a simple affect and a
limited rollout you may be able to do
very well so again ryan we're not sure
but we'll
figure this one out okay uh
let's is that just one other thing is
that like the holographic principle
potentially that
on a system the information about the
system is displayed on its surface
is a markov blanket potentially that
surface that you've observed to
understand the system inside
i believe so and chris fields who will
be
coming onto the stream we'll be talking
about a paper that's going to be
uh in early march chris
has done a lot of holographic markov
blanket
research so let's keep on thinking about
that because that's very
interesting i'm not exactly sure but
yeah
hopefully we'll figure that one out
within a few months so
the paper itself and then again we'll
have enough time just to
hear whatever people are thinking but uh
sophisticated affect of inference we
talked about it in 11.0 and 11.1
and the paper is about combining these
two previous threads of research which
were sophisticated
active inference which is sophisticated
meaning deep through time
with affective inference or active
inference where there's an emotional
state component
the abstract they state that and the
roadmap
of this relatively short paper is pretty
short
so today let's think about how these two
threads which are distinct threads
that's why they each were their own
paper
can be combined into something that is
in front of us today
which is this paper that is literally
summating these two threads of research
and then we can think about a few
directions that
this research makes us think about
whether developing more advanced
simulations so just asking which
parameters of the simulation could be
improved or how could this be expanded
or generalized but also
on the more functional side we can look
to computational psychiatry because
we're talking about emotions
if we are and also even non-human agents
like robots
so a few different directions we can go
and to
structure that discussion it could be
useful for us to
have a few examples like two or three or
four
of sophisticated affective inference
agents
conventional or unconventional so
certainly one of them could be a person
but we'll think of that person being in
a certain context
and then we'll return to these examples
that we come up with right now
as we go through the slides ahead we'll
just return it to example a b c
and then when we're talking about
parameters we'll be able to say okay so
in the example a this matrix would
represent this in the example b
it would represent that so who has a
thought or a suggestion on what would be
like a cool
system to bring into this mixture so
again one of the examples will be a
person
and people can suggest what they think
that person's like story or
situation should be kind of like an
improv scene and then also if people
want to provide
an unconventional system that'd be
good too so
any thoughts on that
alex
i think maybe we can consider
next system scale and see on team
behavior
great and so try to define
these concepts in a meaning of
team communication insight and outside
communication with
different subsystem of organization
thanks for suggesting that so let's do
um example a
is going to be an individual human so
that will be
hopefully grounding us to our lived
experience
into realistic situations that people
and comic book characters find
themselves in
the second example b is going to be team
communication
so we'll kind of develop the story but
we'll see maybe the team is a startup
team or maybe they're a research team
or maybe it's uh just an affinity group
about some other topic and then
the third example let's think about
something more organizational and
institutional so let's think about that
third example being potentially like
a large company large enough to have a
legal department and an hr department
let's just say
so we have three examples which is going
to be the person the team
and the institution slash organization
three levels of analysis
and then as we walk through these
formalisms let's see where might be
like strengths weaknesses limitations
insights etc stephen
and i suppose you could apply it to all
of those this idea you know we have this
vision
and mission i mean that's more for an
organization the mission
and the vision transfers down to a team
which might be the purpose and the roles
and then you've got the kind of the
character and the kind of
you know meaningfulness for the
individual so you've got
this temple depth being sort of
expressed across all of those levels of
scale
yeah exactly like the examples in this
case they're not three disjoint examples
in fact the individual
could be on a team in an organization so
all three of these
examples that we're going to be talking
about could be nested within each other
or they could be disjoint and so that
really highlights why it's so important
to have a multi-scale perspective
because even when we're talking about
the individual we're going to be
thinking about the individual
it's the system of interest it's what
we're talking about it's the interface
we're talking about the markov blanket
that we're talking about
but it's inherently embedded within a
larger system
so we're not going to forget the company
when we're talking about the individual
and vice versa so it's always all the
scales happening at once but then
depending on the system of interest
or the markup blanket or the level of
course graining that is being
uh performed in that specific analysis
it will uh we'll dive into the details
as they present themselves but that will
be kind of
fun so here's figure one
in the paper and we went a little bit in
the previous
videos into some of these sub components
because this is like
m4 and there's m123 as well
that lead up to m4 but just to recap
what each of these pieces are
o at the bottom is observation and s
is the state that inference is being
done upon
so this is where those examples come
into play so in the individual
case the state that's that something
might be having uh
that an individual might be performing
inference on it could be is it sunny or
cloudy
outside and maybe that changes how you
feel or it could be a hidden state like
is this person um happy with me or sad
with me
um a is the mapping of
how these hidden states relate to the
observations
so whether at the individual level it's
sunny outside and then the observations
are perceived with certain probability
um and then yeah people just raise their
hand if they want to like
jump onto another example or uh
you know ask a question about how some
of these variables might interact i'll
just walk through them with no example
and then we'll go to the example pieces
b is how
the states are inferred to change
through time
so the b is like the probability that
given that at state one
it was in such and such a state that at
the next time point it would be at a
different state
now you is a piece that connects to be
and this is the policy and so the policy
is something that influences how states
are likely to transform into each other
the policy itself is downstream of the
agent's decisions
about uh which actions to engage in it
turns out that the way that
the action selection is chosen at the
level of analysis whichever
blanket that we're talking about that is
action selection guided by this set of
parameters
the g is that expected free energy
that's being minimized
and that also covers up the c matrix
which is like the preferences
the gamma is the precision or the
uncertainty
whether it's like one over or not and
basically this relates to how precise
the agent believes they are
in their estimate of which policies to
be pursuing
given this chain of things happening
down here
a um is the uh
is the okay sorry about that at each
time point in this model because i want
to i want to
be general but i want to be specific
about what this model actually did
at each time point in this model that's
being captured by
this top sort of pinkish area this is
the affective inference
question where the affect of the agent
is
relating into how it simulates rolling
out
in this whole internal gray zone all
this these future time points
and um then each model tick
is going to be like moving from the left
to the right
and at each time point in this model the
agent is going to be running out some
uh possibilities for what could happen
in the future so stephen and then we'll
think about the examples
yes so i was going to sort of bring an
example there so maybe
um well one thing that's come up and i
i've been doing some work with this
metaphors of movement and andrew austin
who does that work he talks a lot about
how anxiety he finds anxiety
is often related to people having trying
to have
elevated status like they're trying to
have an elevated status
and it's and it makes a lot of sense for
this because it could also be like
you feel like you put yourself in an
elevated status and
you're always going to be slightly
uncertain
unless maybe you're a king or someone
about that status being maintained
so being put on a pedestal can be so
there could be something about western
society and status which is partly why
we have this
overarching anxiety because
um and it would make sense in a way
because there's
always a sense of never being completely
clear about whether your status is going
to be maintained
so i thought that's kind of interesting
and this would sort of tie
would support that kind of observation
yep so status or um various other
sort of social approval metrics we can
think of it's like
the water we swim in as social organisms
so just like a company might be wanting
to stay above water financially
at least that department a person has to
be staying
above water reputationally we can think
of it in
that way and so again let's go to the
examples and think about these different
systems and what they might be
performing inference on scott
just gonna i'm just gonna comment on the
status
issue that it feels like then you can
adjust so you're making serial
adjustments right you're trying to
minimize the free energy minimize the
difference between your expectation and
the
reality you're experiencing as i
understand it so
with that overall effective status you
can do
what feels like compensating controls
so you could if you feel like you're at
risk
vis-a-vis the one presentation you're
making of self
you can rake in other presentations of
self to complement or supplement or
mitigate the impression of one of them
because
because you have myriad affective
projections that you're making
simultaneously so it feels like if you
have an awareness of this
it can help you with that presentation
of self question
by understanding that you okay this
effective status that i'm presenting
is not getting me where i want to be
inside
so let me leverage another one which is
contiguous or a neighboring
affect again i'll call it an affectation
here but i mean in a
presentation of a markov binding site
um so it feels like it gives a strategy
for
hybridizing and synthesizing your
presentation of your
markov blankets anyway keep going yes
okay so let's go to the examples and
think about how these three
potentially even overlapping systems are
going to be carrying this out
and an individual at each time point
maybe let's just say this is every
second or each minute
a team might be interested in organizing
on the multi-day and the organization is
going to be more explicitly thinking
okay quarter to quarter that's going to
be our next time that we're going to do
all this
simulation so it's not surprising that
as things get bigger
they also get slower so that's a common
theme we're going to see
so the individual's affect is really
where
this emotional inspiration comes from so
there there's the closest mapping
between affect and emotion
but let's think about that team and the
large company example
well affect again and valence
specifically is like that plus
to minus axis so is this team going well
is this company going well and if
someone says yeah we're burning money at
an incredible rate it's unsustainable
but it's going well
because i have a uh believed trajectory
that we're going to go on where we
actually pull out of the nosedive and do
xyz
so they can still think it's going
perfectly well even if the instantaneous
rate of loss
is high and then on the flip side you
can imagine
a team or a large company where
instantaneously their state looks like
it's good it looks like they have a lot
of cash or it looks like they have a lot
of people involved in the team
but they still feel negative about it so
that
disjoint between the affect about a
situation and the state of the situation
is one thing to take into account
now let's connect the affect at all
these levels to precision estimates
at different levels um especially in the
active inference framework which
frames what organisms or any system is
doing as precision seeking
high anxiety is going to be coming from
having low precision now it's not that
we want zero
um uncertainty we want to have this
controlled novelty sort of u
curve but it can be clearly uh
situations where your precision is too
low and then you're surprised by what is
being uh emitted to you in the niche
whether it's your team operating
environment or the company's operating
environment
and then if your precision it can't get
too high because if you're overly
precise and you're incorrect
then you're going to die like if you
have a super super accurate
understanding but you're just delusional
then you're going to fall off the cliff
so in a way what shapes this precision
is actually the real world which prunes
beliefs that are not functionally
associated with success in the real
world steven and then we'll come back to
it
yeah i really like this um this idea of
thinking about how we understand
ourselves within all of this
so for instance yeah if you could move
between
a different regime of attention or sense
of self
which could be like what happens when we
do sense making maybe even change the
operating metaphors
of the person you know who am i at the
moment you know
what's the context what's my situational
um attunement what's my team's purpose
what's what's the operating metaphor for
this team
are we like all driving together in a
car or we
are we building ourselves a fortress you
know and that would
that almost could give a way to jump in
and out of these kind of
affective engines if that makes sense so
as you've seen over time how's it going
what's the policy
um and what's the the affective states
um that sort of thought about in a
certain future and they
could almost then say okay what if i
shifted
maybe that's where you need the body
like the metaphor i'm working with
and then what does that do and um and
maybe at times that's when you need to
work with a group to be able to do that
because maybe
an individual can't just keep
flipping backwards and forwards you need
to work as a group to do that kind of
sense
making across different times
cool scott i had a question for sasha
you were mentioning pruning but you
weren't talking about dendritic pruning
but i wonder if dendritic pruning is
describable by what
the type of pruning you were just
talking about because my understanding
of dendritic pruning
very minimal is that you know during the
day you have the growth of
dendrites and then this pruned back
selectively
um and that that is influenced by your
externality
each day the growth is influenced by
your externality and then there's this
pruning process that feels like it's
iterating itself at that
at that level is that describable by
this here
is that another scale or is it something
else that's going on there
um yeah i think that's a really
interesting analogy
that that's um kind of what's happening
there
i i don't know if i would uh kind of
draw all the same parallels
um yeah just from a mechanistic
standpoint but
it's true that kind of in the
uh in the generalities that um
uh as connections are formed during the
day
then um they're pruned or lost
um as they're not used and yet
we think that happens at night um but
yet i think that's an interesting um
analogy to draw that
it's uh beliefs about the
world that aren't um
i don't know useful or supported are the
ones that then get pruned
yes and oh um i was also gonna say
uh the other aspect
is i think we know uh from our lived
experience is that
it's really um it
it's really interesting when people can
be uh holding certain beliefs
and not um not know that
and then when they finally kind of
confront the the belief
um it kind of yeah
there's a bit of a breakdown and um to
me that that moment is very interesting
um when uh people have to confront
certain beliefs that
um maybe they didn't even recognize that
they held
so there's a phase change and a
recontextualization
piece and the last part you said sasha
and the pruning
is using a network analogy so it's like
pruning connections between different
aspects of the system and so let's think
about the individual
in the uh office having a conversation
with somebody
the query the prompt to them let's just
say is how are you feeling
and that is a query that's presented to
the interface which is their ears
and also their vision and other aspects
the query is presented to the interface
about what's inside of the interface and
now what's happening inside of the
interface
is a generative model of that query
presenting system
so inside of the person there's a
generative model of for example the
person who's talking to them asking that
question
and we know it's a generative model
because if they covered up their eyes or
if they
only heard part of it they might be able
to still recover what was being asked
but in either case there's a generative
model inside of the interface
and a prompt is being presented as an
observation
stimuli to the interface that's querying
how the system will respond so speech is
action
and that's not even a legal claim it's
that it's a motor claim
speech is generated by a motor behavior
it's not your hand but it is a motor
behavior and for some people it is with
their hand
so various body parts can be used to
communicate
let's think about that interface in the
process of the team
and the company so potentially for these
organizational entities
the interface could be like a consultant
who interfaces with specific questions
but instead of a counselor who asks how
are you feeling to an individual
there might be questions that could be
asked to the team
and there can be questions that could be
asked such that only
the team could respond and someone might
say well how could you ask a question
that only a team could respond to aren't
teams composed of people
there's two things i'd say there the
first is that that's the reductionist
argument
the reductionist slide is like what do
you mean get a response from a person
aren't you just going to get a response
from skin cells and neurons
it's like right that's what i'm trying
to get that response
so even if the response can be
reductionistically understood as being
composed of smaller pieces
that's not a surprise that should be
taken for default so
questions can be asked to teams that of
course humans are going to be responding
to as well but also we can think about
kind of like colony phenotypes
we can think about team phenotypes so
for example let's just say i ask a
question to a team
like uh what did you have for lunch or
what do you think the most exciting
project is for next year
and then i looked at the distribution of
how long it took people to respond to
that message that's like a colony level
trait it's a collective trait
that distribution is composed of people
acting
but no individual can dictate what that
distributional parameter is
so it's like a measurement of let's just
say some blood
cells you flow a million blood cells
through and then you can get a
distribution
across all of those blood cells so it's
like you're querying in the aggregate
even though each individual sub piece uh
could have been
following that distribution or uh
somewhat of an outlier
so those are the kinds of things that
you could ask
presenting to a team or an organization
and the team of the organization is
going to have a generative model of its
niche
so if it's involved in a certain type of
consultancy where it paid a lot of money
and it really respects what the person
is going to be
uh doing then maybe when you ask them
the question what's the most exciting
project and why
they give one response or what's the
most challenging
project of this year and why was it
challenging whereas if you were in a
different context you'd give a different
response
because the generative model of the
system across that interface is very
different so the response that it gives
will be different
and it's going to be querying different
things and externalizing different
aspects of itself could be accurate
could be
inaccurate scott so one of the things
that raises is i've been in some of the
work that i've done in cyber security
i've been
parsing principles versus ethics versus
norms
and so it's kind of interesting in
querying a group they're going to get an
average right you'll get a gaussian
distribution or whatever of
opinion and you'll then it'll be
informative um
in and so norms i assert
for these purposes that their behaviors
with behavioral expectations that are
set through the past what was normal
and one of the assertions i make is
principles and again they're assertions
there's different overlap
here the principles are institutional
assertions of aspiration
and ethics also are aspirational but
they're human assertions about
human behaviors that's the distinction i
make whatever words you want to use
and so it's interesting in the context
where you're talking about about
querying a group
because there's different evidentiary
group
chunks that you'll look at right
normative you'll be looking if
according those definitions on hey
what'd we do before
and would we do against the set of
standards that said the principles may
be more aspirational
and it may be you know how we doing
towards that thing
but it's not necessarily based on what
was done before you can
you know you say our principles are more
aspirational than what we did before
so it's interesting just that interface
of what's used
in the discussion of the group dynamics
and how that relates to what you were
just describing which is the querying
of the group and individuals the framing
of the nature of that
output you're getting from the group is
kind of interesting based on that
question asked
right what do you do before is one
question what do you wish to do in the
future is a different question
yes so that query could be what do you
regularly do
so again it could be the person in the
office and someone says what is your
morning routine that's something we
talked about in a previous week
or it could be a query to a team what is
your onboarding
routine or how do you welcome new
members
um and then this question of the
aspirational and the norm so
it's funny because norms can mean what's
normal
it means what's expected that's what has
happened
in the past because what's not normal
you know if not if not the past
what's normal but at the same time
normative
means uh what should be so a normative
claim should be like i think people
should be treated this way
and that may or may not reflect what has
been the norm
so people all of uh belief systems make
normative claims
that sometimes are consistent with norms
and sometimes
are almost radically divergent from
norms
someone says the norm is a but i think
the norm
should be b so i'm making a normative
claim about the norms and it should be
different and so these are all
interesting things to uh yeah scott
so one big gap that's out there in the
world right now is the gap between
law and what the interactions that
technology allows
and i'm talking about fractally up and
down the chain
reproductive interactions biomedical
population wide all these different
things the law is really lagging
okay so one of the things that's
interesting about this is
there a possibility that this kind of
analysis can help us to discover
norms that would guide
groups and those norms if they're
sufficiently
interesting to the groups can be made
enforceable into laws
and so that to me this is a very
interesting way of a
possibility of discovery of new laws
and self-constraints that groups can put
on themselves in order to function as
larger systems in the globe kind of
context
but i'll put that aside for now but i
just wanted to raise that is is this a
discovery is this a mechanism for
discovery
of new working models of larger scale
norms yes stephen
yeah i think that that this is a good
point because
and and discovering that with this model
here where you've got this
task specific and then you've got this
effective
actually as a largest sort of scale
time scale sort of checking i think it's
also relevant in terms of how we can get
mechanized in our like if we just keep
doing the same task
and we get the reward in the queue and
it starts to
create a high sense of this false sense
of certainty
in our world which is so much about just
constructing more
of our social niche and alienating or
externalizing the environmental
so we we can start to get caught up in
this kind of task specific
ways of working in silos and so there
may be there's
this this could speak to why we need to
do some sort of sense breaking
to sort of take us out of some of these
mechanizations and
look at a longer time scale
and use affect to do that integration
and not just rely on metrics
cool let's let's take scott's point
about this being
not just an enforcement understanding
but a discovery process
and connect that to some topics we've
been considering like bottom-up versus
top-down
function of systems so the bottom up is
learning that's where the little ants
are going out and they're finding
different things or
each of the cells in the retina is
receiving a different photon or
each person is receiving a different
news feed and then
as it goes quote up or in the system
it's being aggregated and that is
updating progressively
more and more summary like variables
like
of teams or of organizations and then
norms can feed back down to lower levels
of the system
whether in the brain like the bayesian
brain or the predictive processing
hypothesis or whether it's team
communication
norms and those can be informal or
formal
when we're talking about human
organizations we gain this level of
syntactic framing of top down priors
so instead of just saying this is how
things are like the red blood cells are
flowing at this speed so that's the
speed they're flowing at
we're going to say there's a speed limit
and if you don't follow the speed limit
then we're going to have this type of
enforcement mechanism
and so it could be the case that at in
the legal
context that if you just apply a law
a top down law it's kind of like trying
to teach someone a motor pattern
uh let's just say a speech law of some
type of controlling speech
it's like controlling someone's motor
behavior again because it
is a motor behavior and so what would
you do would you put them in the
exoskeleton
and say okay here's a perfect golf swing
now you're a golfer
right well no you actually need to
practice
and you need to have feedback and so if
the law
is overly punitive and it says oh that
one time that you got put in the
exoskeleton you didn't understand how to
golf
and other sports that golfers know how
could you not have made the connection
there from that one time that i punished
you for messing up
that is not an extremely helpful
framework for certain issues so how
could we have this
bi-directional conversation where
there's experimentation
and implementation at the edges and then
people's experience percolates upwards
in the system
and then the system informally but
eventually formally
ends up entrenching healthy or
productive
or agreed upon patterns so
it's an interesting thought about how
these type of systems
are not just about learning
they're not just about exploitation as
we've been thinking about they're sort
of
in both domains and they can trade off
and when they need to exploit they can
dip into exploitative
uh type behavior but also they can be in
an exploratory mode
scott and it's also so much
wrapped up in identity it's amazing how
this is a new platform for identity
because every thing has a markov blanket
and it has attributes and
external attributes that are presented
and so
the discovery when you have things like
trade associations markets communities
of interest
where things entities
with similar um
i guess markov blankets and attributes
can cluster together
forming those systems which have larger
scale which enable
de-risking and leverage for the organism
or organization at
larger levels so the discovery process
of bringing these
markets are where markov blankets are
um made similar
right because you go in and there's a
law it says if you're going it's your
flea market
your table can only be five by five so
if you go in with a seven by five table
you can't go to that flea market you
have to follow the rules to be part of
the club
but if you're in the club you get the
power of having more people walking past
your
table to sell stuff so there's the
interface the law
for the vendor to the flea market and
then within
that transaction there's a sub
transaction which is if you want this
little pocket knife
you're going to give me three dollars
and then i'll give you the pocket knife
so these are the nesting of agreements
in the context of identity and enforced
and unenforced norms
blue and then stephen
so just to kind of tie into what both
you and scott were saying so like
you know for ants and we're going
through the world like building
this generative model like as we
discover as we're learning right like so
as we learn
we build the generative model like to
what extent is
our generative model tied into our
identity
like that's um it's curious to think
about and and
i mean i know that like there's a policy
update and perhaps the policy is more
based on identity like we talked about
earlier like the running every day
uh maybe it's it's a policy thing that's
identity and so the we pick the
the policy that that then minimizes the
free energy but but i just wonder like
you know the the generative model
how frequently that that he builds upon
the identity like what the relationship
is between those two
okay and then stephen
yeah well one thing that sort of ties
into that question of identity
and this this type of model is
and the markov blanket i suppose is how
much changes
based on the diet
that the processing which could be like
this
in the brain could be sort of structured
through
the way the brain is structured so there
could be an additional type of
structuring
going on in which all of this is able to
work together
and then so how much is is this kind of
the observations and the states in the
sort of brain
computating in relation and with the
body
and how much is it just literally the
way the markov blanket itself
is changed you know so and i think
that's maybe an open question at the
moment because
there's the question i don't think as
much as the idea of regimes of attention
has been talked about but
literally how would that change your
computation by bringing in
different parts of the body and the
relation to the environment
as the sort of marker blanket to
integrate
information coming in and how much is
through computation and i sense that
that at certain times maybe when you're
learning something for the first time
it's very computationally heavy but then
as you draw things down and it becomes
kind of tacit knowledge
we might become subconsciously able to
flow
and shift yes formal systems
can become integrated through muscle
memory
so somebody who's learning how to play
violin they don't need to know the math
of the frequency overlap they might
learn that in their journey
but also it becomes incorporated through
culturally acquired practices
and muscle memory and that could be
carried out into other areas
scott there was an article just read
recently in nature or science which
relates to
the steven's last point and it was about
how
in in cultures where there were deaf
cultures so they're isolated populations
i think there was one in central america
there was one in the middle east
of deaf people because it was some kind
of genetic thing and so large
populations of isolated people who are
deaf
and what they found is when they came up
with their independent sign languages
they were all independently generated
what they found in this research is they
used the body
in each of the isolated populations
the body was used in the same
way different parts like first thing
i've i'm going to make up the
parts because i can't remember them but
they would first use the face parts then
they would use the left arm then they
would use the right arm then they would
use the core of the body
the morphology of speech through sign
language
was identical across the human
populations even though they were
isolated from each other
in terms of what they added on i forget
what it was with the bigger concepts or
the
the things that were emotional there
were different morphologies
of that i guess situating their
expression
in their morphology in other parts of
their morphology so
i thought it would relate to that i'm
not sure how but it feels
like that form of expression being
uniform across humans it's like the um
theories of
humans having a language capacity i
forget who's that is
maybe mcluhan or somebody anyway but
it's interesting that the morphology of
the body
that sounds like there's some intrinsic
um
uh tearing of what expression comes
through what parts of the body
i'll try to find very interesting and
that actually reminds me
of william blake's poetry and the
four-fold albion
which is a metaphor for cosmic persona
as well as all of england as well as the
individual body
and so it's a metaphor that he returns
to many times
in an allegorical context and it's so
evocative
because it speaks to a multi-scale
system
and it is of course applying to
multi multi-scale systems steven
yeah thanks for that uh scott because i
think that's
i mean that could actually also you know
there's all this thing about this innate
language capacity which has now been
kind of discounted but
i mean if actions first and their
morphology
is maybe more related certainly within
certain
you know environmental niches that
people have grown up in
um that would maybe explain why there
was that confusion in the language world
because people sort of saw a language
universe well actually if the
morphologies
where it's at and language is just an
another type of morphology that's kind
of building on the core morphology of
the body
that's where that patterning was coming
from not the language itself
or the languaging process look and
i was just going to say extending that
out further one of the assertions that
i've
started to make and and believe is that
the mind doesn't reside in the brain at
all the mind resides in language and in
material culture and the brain is an
antenna
that we tune into the local mind
wherever
we're exposed to that's why colonialists
put indigenous
populations children in their schools
right they take they want to
tune their mind into a colonialist
culture
early because they then renders the
externality innocuous for their
colonialism
anyway yes that's true of all children's
education
including contemporary and to bring in
this key
point of precision um again active
inference is not about systems finding
the most rewarding state and then
sticking with it
it's about precision so to connect that
to identity
um the child's education is being uh
it's basically
being given symbols that will help it
navigate the regularities in its niche
and again there can be dysfunctional
education that leads to children that
are
incapable of taking advantage or of
working with the regularities
in the niche but this is where the
policy selection piece comes into play
to kind of return it to the figure
because that's like important to return
to what the paper said
is the policy selection piece is so
tied up with identity it's not that
there's an identity like who we are and
then there's this totally separate
question of what we do
it actually is we are how
we act and to even take it to another
level
the understanding of how the world
changes s
the states that are external that we
care about the understanding of how
those states change is
related to the policy actions that the
system takes
and so that even brings this relational
mode
another level deeper it's not just like
say pure wharf
oh well the words that you use change
how you think or they influence how you
think
it's everything is influential on how we
think because
how we think is like this emergent
outcome from all those factors
so it's a starting point to say that the
words that we have
or the affordances or the sensory
capacities that we have
shape our understanding of the niche
that's the starting point blue
so just to piggyback on the idea of a
team
and identity like like how and also
where the mind is like where is the mind
of a team
right like when you're when you're
thinking about this in terms of active
inference
and so the the individual team members i
mean we've all worked on teams before
at various points and it's amazing how
the team
changes based on the like the function
of its individual components right like
so there are different people that bring
different dynamics to a team
some people may be louder stronger or
less influential
or or everyone has a different kind of
role in a team
and and these all like really bring
changes to the overall structure and the
way that the team will
react right like like based on a query
like when you query a team
you know what is the best project of the
year that'll change based on
the the individual components of that
team
yep and the team organism mapping
let's think about team onboarding and
the way that the interface of the
organism
is like an interface of a team so the
immune system of a person
there's times where something is
onboarded but in a very controlled way
and it does not trigger
the immune system so for example if you
eat something
in the stomach which is a specialized
chamber that digests food
it is then absorbed through the
interface of the gut
in a controllable way in a way where
only the safe pieces like you know that
the sugars are coming in and the amino
acids are coming in lipids are coming in
so through that controlled and
evolutionarily selected upon interface
there is an onboarding process that's
healthy but if there's a
onboarding event on your body like a cut
in your skin
it's going to trigger the immune system
so that's more like a security breach
for a team
whereas eating for a team might be like
hey we're going to get this
ingest of new data our colleague is
going to send us a data set
it's going to come from this email
address and it's this type
if it's from a different email address
i'm not going to see it or if it's of a
different type we're going to need to
change our pipeline
but if it's this type of food coming at
this interface and it's
you know this structure we're going to
be able to digest that
and then use the information latent in
that
input to help our team become more
structured
or to expand just like an organism would
break down the food and
use it to grow itself or to operate
stephen
and also with teams you've got the the
teleology
of the team like the purpose the goals
and
i think that that i mean this figure's
sort of speaking lots of task based
you know ways of things being evaluated
with rewards
and the way that we structure our teams
often with
the way that we then construct the
environment to sort of
lead us towards those rewards in a way
and i'm really interested in looking at
this thing called infusion space that
i've been working on is
when we are in a kind of an organized
space with a teleology and a direction
like a team an organization and then
when we're in a sort of community
uh space where which maybe this isn't
i think is another process of affect
where we're sort of attuning
to um that kind of inter-subjective
dynamic
between us and you know there's there's
one's more efficient the team's more
efficient if your goal is the right goal
the danger is that you could be
they talk about now with the modern
world as we're getting very good at
doing the wrong things
so it can be the trap you fall into so
climate change being a classic case
we're very good
doing things we shouldn't be doing so i
think there's an interesting
question there about a teleological
dynamic
aligned to goals and rewards which
everything's then
and it could actually remove the knowing
of your affect
and you can just ignore it because
you're getting other kicks
and when the deeper knowing is like you
know it's not really going to be good
when you talk about really long time
scales
okay let's expand on that so teleology
is coming from the word teleos which is
the end so teleology is the study
in philosophy of what systems are as
defined by their ends so the purpose of
something like
houses are to keep people warm and what
are people for
but instead of engaging in the
philosophy of teleology like what does
it mean to be a human what are we here
for
we can think about it from a cybernetics
perspective which is
also equivalent to like an intentional
stance in philosophy
and that's kind of like saying like okay
look whether or not we're ever going to
figure out the ultimate
teleos of a human or the ultimate teleos
of our team
at the very least as a goal seeking
system that has to operate amidst
uncertainty
and communicate through limited and
noisy channels
we need to have clarity on our mission
our local telios
so that we can have clarity on action
and again if your local mission
is something that is uh pursuable
then it's it's a second layer whether
it's quote good or bad
and that's the whole question about what
scott
raised with the markov blankets of legal
entities
and there it's kind of easy to see some
of the analogies between let's say a
society and a person
if each cell were to fight for its
markov blanket
then things could get hairy pretty fast
whereas over evolutionary time
the interfaces between cells of the
organism have evolved through so many
different proteins and so many different
mechanisms to work well
together to be compatible within the
organism and similarly
within a healthy operating system for
legal entities
you could imagine there would be healthy
interfaces but in the absence of a
healthy interface
then even entities whose interests are
completely aligned
might end up in extremely adversarial
context together
scott and i think that might be the
problem with kant's emanuel kant's
uh what is it called the something
imperative
category yes and is that the notion that
if the
a human acts a good human acts in a good
way it'll be good for
society so uh
the kantian imperative as it's uh called
a categorical imperative sometimes uh
it's uh i'm just i just wanted to look
up an exact word
it is quoted as a rule of conduct that
is unconditional or absolute for all
agents the validity of claim
of which does not depend on any desire
or end
that and yeah that reads heavily as that
classic era of abstraction
in philosophy and that's one of the
problems in european law right now in an
identity law like gdpr and those kind of
things in the real world
their idea of entities and of identity
is based on hegel and kant
and those are there there is a real
focus on that individual
being good and that being enough to have
the entire society work well
and i think that's part of the prob
challenges over there
they then continental law you make the
law
and you refer back to the statute all
the time
in common law which is any place that
was part of the
british empire you what you do is you
come up with a
half-assed version of the law and then
you allow common law to fix it up
so the common law acts as a continually
dynamic
revisiting um because the courts then
make the law and then when you when you
have a later case you don't just look at
the original statute you look at the
cases as
well the other court cases and so it's
been modified by that so one of the
things that this gets tangled up in
is philosophically a question of how
much of a teleology you have
i believe my personal belief is that
because they had royalty a tradition of
royalty on the european continent
that they're more amenable to a single
voice and so that single voice can act
in a misdirected way for a longer period
of time
because it projects onto a paradigm onto
the population
but it's just something that it gets
softer at that level perhaps
because we don't know the data and the
metrics but it feels like those same
kind of
things are iterating from a system
perspective if you have something that's
too stuck in the mud
it's not going to change as fast and now
that's happening everywhere since
technology
moore's law increases interactions
exponentially
all of our institutions all of them were
intended to de-risk and leverage much
more leisurely
institutional contexts so they're no
longer fit for function in the
interaction landscapes we have
and so one of the questions is does how
in what way might this analysis
help us to not just improve all the
institutions that might not be possible
but construct institutions that can
better
be dynamic with the increased frequency
and volume
of interactions we have which is
perceived by any one
institution as an increase in density
interaction density
that's why your calendar is all jammed
up because we're still using calendars
the way we used to use them which is
linear progression of things they have
to do things like that so
anyway sorry about the question there
yeah interesting stephen
well that might now that also might tie
into this idea of when
we have systems in our niche that we've
created when
you know when do we need them to be more
attunable to
our own active inference types of
dynamics like if we if this is the type
of way that we
can you know what would help us be
better at attuning and what types of
attention
at what types of scale would we want
this kind of dynamical
process and when does it want to be
fixed and it kind of speaks another
problem
in the development world was the right
based approach
to development so someone somewhere
defines what
people's rights are and what's the and
then it gets dictated down but that
causes a lot of problems when you roll
out into cultures which
value things slightly different to those
that decided what's right and it's also
what's right for someone
in a poor context or a poverty context
might not be quite it is with someone in
a
in a developed wealthy context so the
same
you know maybe this is a question that
needs to be asked is when do we need to
have
this kind of active inference ergodic
help
you know thought about crit and when do
we say look this isn't being done that
way we're just going to bolt it down and
use a non-ergodic
kind of structured state of this sort of
laws okay interesting
so let's try to connect that to uh cont
and then back to action
because that's the key piece and that's
what we really want to emphasize with
the active inference
approach is that although we generalize
we're generalizing to reduce our
uncertainty about
observations which could be letters or
sounds that we're hearing
we're reducing our uncertainty about the
stimuli that we're as people receiving
by generalizing so that we can guide
action and so the categorical imperative
on wikipedia it says it's best known
from its first formulation
act only according to that maxim whereby
you can at the same time
will that it should become a universal
law so that's actually also
related in a sense like a symmetry
relationship with the rawlsian theories
of justice
like what would be fair would be if you
were to be a random draw
you'd want to be in that society versus
another society
but here's where active inference and
action and the reality of the finite
world come into play
different people have different risk
preference trade-offs so maybe somebody
says yeah
i'll take a one in a million chance of
being the dictator and somebody else
says no i'd rather
have a 100 chance of being in this other
world where everyone has the exact same
amount of official power for example
but even at a deeper level that's a
thought discussion
and it's becoming increasingly lifted
from action and from policy selections
that we
as the agents perceiving that question
are being faced with
and so when people bring in the things
like it should become a universal law
that's a normative claim about a
universalism about a law
you know and who's the judge jury
executioner so although the sentence
the imperative started with act
according to
it ended up in the clouds with some
speculation
about what could or would or should
become universal
and ostensibly enforced by other people
with weapons but not yourself
so how do we tie it back to the real
system
and confront ourselves with what we
actually are being faced with
from an affordance and from a challenges
perspective and then
ask what policies will help guide the
whole system
towards states that we want to see but
at first we can just acquire precision
about
who are we what are our relationships
what are our interfaces
how can we think in a more rigorous
multi-scale way
about how we are composed of our
relationships
so not that i'm some atom and i'm being
influenced by my relationships but
it's multi-scale relationships all the
way up and down so
what is really happening here these are
some interesting ways that sidestep
morality when working together but they
sidestep
the ways that morality has been framed
in terms of well i think it should
become a universal law that
i should get all the money and then it's
easy for me to act within the
categorical imperative under that
understanding
when someone says well no that's not the
real understanding and then you're right
back to square zero
so how are we going to use systems
thinking
but also include aspects of
intercultural communication and
understanding that people are going to
be having different experiences of the
same deal
the same interface different people are
going to have different experiences of
it
and then work within that environment so
that's kind of
you know some big areas that hopefully
we'll be thinking about
in the coming years because they're uh
serious questions about how to interface
formal systems with people scott
one of the things that's interesting
right now in law is that you know it's
really showing
wear and tear and people are really
focusing on liability
and rights and things like that which is
terrific but one of the things the right
is an is an expectation and
what the law does is it constructs a
bunch of duties around that right that
give
life to the right so if i say have a
right to free speech and nobody has a
duty to respect it then i don't have
anything except words on paper
and so the duties the construction of
duties what that does
is its constraint on other uh expression
other markov blankets right you're
limiting and constraining
the environment of other individuals
you'll meet because they have a duty to
do
x the duty to there's a judge who said
years ago in the united states
your right to swing your head arm in
public ends where my nose begins
right so you can keep doing this until
my nose is next to where you're swinging
your arm
so it's interesting isn't it that you
have this that is really that dynamic
element if
a nose is introduced into that system
you got to stop swinging your arm
right and so the anticipation of
situations where you shouldn't swing
your arm don't swing your arm in an
elevator
you know that kind of thing right don't
don't spit on the subway right you start
to have these rules which are like hey
we can generalize that
duty to a population and if it's
relatively innocuous
like red means stop
purple could mean stop it's not the
light that stops the car it's the
behavior
elicited by the signal so there are a
lot of innocuous things we can
avoid avoidable harms by agreeing on
innocuous signaling for certain duties
and behaviors
that would render those rights to be
realized and to be
living yep so with this kind of eating
team metaphor ingestion of stimuli
or a food at the organism level and
that's being processed
either chemically with food or
informationally with the stimuli
in order to guide action so we can think
about these teams and organizations
as getting inputs and then engaging in
action in their niche
and the goal of the inputs and selection
is going to shape this
is so that the inputs can be processed
in a way
that leads to outputs that are effective
and so
again another mapping would be to a heat
system so like an engine if you can
convert 100 of the potential energy
into work it's a very efficient system
and it doesn't lose a lot to heat
whereas if you have a system that's
broken or has inefficiencies in it
it will perform very little work in its
task specific
uh role and it will release a lot as
heat which is like wasted energy that's
like data
exhaust there's wasted data there's so
many mappings here
actually in the last couple minutes
let's just run through the slides see if
anything comes to mind but
other than that i'm sure we could keep
on you know thinking about this
figure two of the paper the authors
showed this
rollout game and uh the agent at each
time point
is imagining what could happen on future
timelines
and so here's a timeline where i stay in
this neutral state on the left side
here's a timeline where
i get to state three and that's good
then i go to state four and it's bat and
so
as you simulate and you roll out more
and more and more
deeply that's the sophisticated or the
deep component
as you roll that out in order to track
what uh kind of a world you're in are
you in a world where all the routes are
bad or all of them are good or some are
goods or bad
the agent is tracking a few things it's
tracking the state estimates like the
expected value
of different policy choices but also the
variance or the uncertainty
and what we saw in this paper was that
as the agent starts initially thinking
and simulating deeply it starts to be
perceiving itself
in states that are rewarding and it has
relatively high precision about being
able to maintain itself in those states
but as it continues to simulate deeper
and deeper
the precision of its model drops this is
associated with
anxiety from the computational
psychiatry perspective
and uh it's also associated with the
increased percentage
of the events being negative but not a
10x increase in the events being
negative and as we pointed out last time
it's actually when the threat perception
is at a medium level
when the anxiety skyrockets and again
this specific
trace is just related to the parameters
of this model so it's not meant to be a
general claim about anxiety or something
like that
it is for future work to really map this
onto real world
systems we had the formalisms which
people can
pause and look at
the formalisms of sophisticated
inference
and the real
natural language translations of some of
these variables that are interacting
in these papers we talked about the
generalized
free energy and about how that formalism
has a few different parts
one of those parts is conditioned on
policies
and it talks about the relational
mapping between observations and states
and then the other function here is
conditioned
on policy and it's uh yeah
sorry let me just rephrase that one of
these sides is conditioned on policy
and relates to states the other side is
conditioned on observations and states
and it relates to policy selection
um we talked about a few other topics
intrinsic and external value
general and special cases and how
when you are moving through a prediction
in this branching way there's an
exponentially increasing
number of states and so in order to deal
with that
organisms or systems have to engage in a
little bit more of a guided
kind of search and that brings us to
this slide which is what i kind of
wanted to pause on because i think blue
this is what
made you say we have to invite scott
so what what was interesting to you here
what made you think of that
just uh scott and how um scott's always
presenting on risk and this just was
like well
i think that scott really needs to be
here and based on also the fact that
scott
um said he'd been studying active
inference since
the october complexity weekend so those
two things kind of
nailed it for me cool i feel like it's a
it's this giant thing a smorgasbord
that's in the next room that i haven't
yet
entered into that's it's it's so
delightful i'm so
thrilled by my ignorance in this this is
the best
gift i could ever get so thank you all
you know
it's like a room to room party you just
go room to room and it's always a new
setting
but we're bringing the party along
because it's
enacted it's not that there's a room of
researchers or a community that's
waiting
for us to be onboarded onto we're
co-domesticating each other
and creating the community that we want
to see so that's self-organization and
multi-scale organization
in action and we can think about that
actually
tying it back to this figure so the
active inference
framework under special cases which were
described in this
slide we can think about
a few different cases where certain
things are driven to zero
so when there's no uncertainty
about states in other words states of
the world can be perfectly known
then risk-sensitive policies can be
enacted
so um when there's no ambiguity about
states
you can talk about risk that's this part
right here
however when there is ambiguity about
states
you have to reduce that uncertainty and
that's sort of like
if you don't know what the states of the
system are
you can't operate but to the extent you
have reduced ambiguity about the
observations in states you're able to
increasingly plan
risk sensitive policy so scott that
makes me think about
in a world of digital transactions where
we can have reduced uncertainty
about certain types of events happening
could we then
move some of that energy and focus to
risk-aware
policy so that's one piece here that's
why i call what we have right now a
self-boiling ocean
nice so that's the that's the saddle
meme this is still within the context of
how most people think about ambiguity
and uncertainty
vuca that's in the terms of minimization
of two different things
minimize uncertainty minimize risk first
go ahead and reduce your uncertainty
about the states
and then to whatever extent you can do
that reduce our uncertainty about the
future vis-a-vis reducing risk
that's the normal framework for most
people
or at least it's one way to think about
it but now
let's think about it um active inference
not just in a risk
controlled way but in this bayesian
statistical framework
a variational framework where we're
actually doing
not just a double minimization but we're
doing like a push
pull with a minimization and an
exploration simultaneously
so we're going to be able to dynamically
adjust explore exploit it's not exactly
explore exploit as we talked about but
it's like explore exploit because we can
dynamically adjust the relative pressure
or weighting
of the in and the out so we're always
exploring
and we're also always reducing our
uncertainty
about the system and so that's why the
uh
two arrows are moved into an overlapping
uh area just graphically this is just a
loose graphical model here
because not it's not a disjoint two-step
process
ambiguity about states and then
ambiguity about risk
if we have certainty about states this
is the co
joint estimation of all these pieces
together in a way that's a push-pull
so there's a couple paradigm-changing
ways of framing
risk and operating in this mode
and that will lead to different types of
institutional structures that will be
distributed which will resemble
neighborhood watch
but it won't just be neighborhood watch
it'll be neighborhood creation as well
that's a fundamental change exactly
instead of just putting up the law at
like a trip wire and then triggering it
yeah you could say how do we just have
people who are going on a neighborhood
walk
just people walking the neighborhood
it's like you know like they could
just having fun and being social could
that be the actual
thing and so it fuses several of the
previous ways of thinking about it well
we're going to reduce our uncertainty
about what's happening in the
neighborhood
and then we're going to do a risk
minimization policy well this makes you
think
about installing surveillance cameras
but what if you said we're going to
jointly be discovering
what community norms we have and what we
want to be aspirationally as a
neighborhood
around safety or around communication
and maybe there's a way where we can
just go on walks in the afternoon
and all of a sudden people are
connecting and it's a safer world
and the other just one other thing i
once read an article about the world
champion
fly tie tire and he tied flies and they
were the best most successful flies for
catching fish
but all the people complained that his
flies didn't look like
actual insects they didn't fool humans
and he said i don't have to fool the
humans i just had to fool the fish
and so the reason i say that here is the
way we're going to do this is we're
going to use the left side we're going
to get people in by saying hey you got
risk
what have you been doing about the risk
let's talk about the risk okay that's
fine
we're going to get other people in the
room who are going to be talking about
the same risk but they
people never met each other before and
then by the time they leave the room
they're going to be in the right-hand
side of the design
that's where the governance is going to
shift we're going to hook them with
something they re
they recognize like the fish guy we're
going to hook them with the thing on the
left which is hey risk we're going to
talk about risk that's what the atlas
of risk i'll send it around to the other
folks but some of you have it
it's 870 different information risks
that are shared by people now because
digital stuff has made everybody have
trouble so they
come for the risks they know but by the
time they leave they're going to be
organized into different groups that
aren't going to be dealing with the risk
the risk was
the existing risk description was just a
way to get them in the room
yes yes so one metaphor before stephen
instead of let's let's measure your
blood measure your blood measure your
blood so that we can measure your risk
of the disease
this is like how could we be doing
active inference
on health and working towards health in
a way that yeah maybe we'll do a
measurement here or there
and we do want to reduce risk and we
will reduce risk
but we're actually framing it in a way
that's like a journey
related to health in mind rather than
ambiguity
risk disease negative negative negative
uncertainty
anxiety how about yin and yang
with a little bit of a more balanced
understanding about how we can function
and enact policy stephen
this is a very important diagram
actually
like you're saying this this takes us
away from just trying to reduce
uncertainty about the external stimuli
and the kind of
locked in risk aversion and you're
actually working more with that
time dependent or time series
um approach that active inference gives
of like well how are things changing and
how
just like that fish looking at the the
fly
how does that embodied agent
and the wisdom and recognizing that
there's a wisdom
about how to be in the world and how to
be with your niche
how is that actually being used
to inform how we make things happen and
not just this more mechanical
approach yes and
good points there um in
active inference stream 19 yonder
in mid april we're going to have deeply
felt affect
which is one of the papers that was
cited in this paper but we're going to
go into it in more detail
we'll talk about perception about
anticipation
action metacognition implicit
metacognition
and just to close out i listed a few
questions um do people want to hang out
for a few more
minutes and talk for a little bit yeah
it sounds good but
i'll just give the closing slider then
we'll return to the question slide
thanks everyone for
participating the live viewers
uh have a link to a feedback form in the
event
everyone else really thanks so much for
super special and unique experience for
all of us
so really deeply appreciated for those
watching live or
in replay or whenever wherever it was
great
times so thanks a lot and we're just
getting started so
for a little bit longer whoever wants to
stay and if you want to leave just
just no worries just drop off but um
what's something that somebody wants to
go into here or what's something that
still people want to
bring up
one of the one of the things i'm
wondering about is just the
we've been taking this from a single
individual perspective to some extent
and in those group perspectives this
kind of it's interesting that
the simultaneity of all of it that the
you you know you simultaneously have an
individual
that's this the how do we get a handle
how do we help people get a handle on
the the
many levels that operate simultaneously
and then one of the
it then then how do we bring that to the
current time the now
where everyone is acting in this moment
you know reading another paper now on
fractal time and they say
hey the past and the future don't exist
if they do where are they show me
right so the idea is now is all that
exists so we have these
priors which were that and we have these
future projections which are that but we
have the now
and we all act in the now and all these
myriad
dynamics feed into the now
and so it's such an interesting notion
to me of how
to trim tab systems as a lawyer
you don't just we don't just observe
we're always trying to push things in
one direction or another for clients
right
or for whatever and so it feels like
it's such an interesting thing that we
have it's not just a now we have a
series of nows
available to us i guess because we in
the diagram you see a series of now's
right
in the in the steps so
it's interesting to that temporal aspect
is something that's
just not brought into so many systems
right they're so static in so many ways
and so in a sense like when you work
with standards people they'll say oh it
has to be
robust so that we can plan based on it
but it also has to be flexible
and it feels like this naturally this
analysis
naturally lends itself once it becomes
an institutionalized thing because our
institutions now are not
built on these analyses but once they're
built on the dynamics
where they're built on i'll use the word
uncertainty but it's really
embracing uncertainty or as i said in
i called it entropy engines we were
actually mining disorder
in order to create order so anyway
just a couple of things that thoughts
that came to mind it feels like that
time issue
is relevant to our understanding how we
can
mind disorder cool stephen
yeah the time issue is definitely a big
part and we see that with these papers
we've seen that there's the narrative
approaches there's the reflective and
now they're trying to get into the
pre-reflective more
and traditionally that's been you know
meditation but
what is the way that we understand these
different time scales and i
what i'd be interested in is is how does
this link in with affordances i think
there's something really interesting
about
that niche and the affordances in a
niche because it gives away
because it's sort of permanent therefore
you know like that the path could still
be there the cups can still be there
yet my interaction with it can vary
so i think that that's a a really
interesting
um way that experiments can tie a lot of
this information or knowledge together
sure so one idea we've talked a lot
about is the idea of attracting sets or
attracting
states so for the perspective of your
body with regards to temperature
you want to be attracting back to core
body temperature
excursions outside of that range are not
just bad they're lethal
so attracting states are really
important and just like you can have
attracting sets of states on a single
number line like temperature you can
have
in the wandering itinerant dynamics of
thought you can have attracting
thoughts and you can ruminate and you
get too attracted or it can be too
precise but
it's an idea that people could be
familiar with or not
that attracting states can be thoughts
so let's think about active inference
the framework
as an attracting state as something
where we can in a room bring
up these ideas and refocus the
discussion or potentially expand or
uh zoom in so we've brought up this
multi-scale
and the deep past in the deep future so
it's multi-scale through space like the
nested systems and then there's
multi-scale through time
there's molecules vibrating and then
there's longer term things
so let's start with the multi-scale
space and time just being our starting
position
and then active inference goes further
it says not just is it going to start
being multi-scale in space and time but
there's going to be non-linearity in
uncertainty because there are causes in
the world
so rj and his alarm clock and his dog
and something that you wouldn't expect
changed in the world
and that changed another part of the
world that you basically wouldn't have
expected
um and also our action is always going
to be constrained by our situational
affordances in the niche
so to steven's point there which is like
it's all good to think about
objectively what's happening but
constrained by affordances in the niche
that we're actually in
is the operating conditions we have so
it makes sense to at least ground the
discussion
in the affordances and then we're
presented with attracting set of
questions
like how will we work together to be
agents in a system of the type we would
like to see
that's a question that in various
settings people could say
oh well we don't have clarity on what
kind of system
we want to be in we need to reduce our
uncertainty
about what kind of system we're in
that's visioning
and clarifying mission but then there's
other times where people say
yeah how do we be the agents of this
kind of a system that we want to be in
so we're not uncertain about the mission
about the end
cybernetically but i'm just like
honestly confused about what next role i
should take
in this system to make this happen
according to the
this mission that we've laid out and if
my actions are consistent with the
mission as we've laid it out then
they're good
but if they're not then they're just not
helpful so
we can start to combine a lot of these
ideas
and realize hopefully that whether we go
deep into the physics side or into
another
aspect of active inference we'll use it
as an attracting set
and as this range in face space where we
can bring the discussion
and help ground it in the multi-scale
insights
in the non-linearity of the world and a
few other things
but i think it's really yeah and they
really are
they really are that
like we we start our diagram with
entities that have priors right we're
not starting
we i mean you could start with no priors
and you're just
wandering around in the dark in the
woods
but we're starting with a system that
has
something that we comparing the reality
to
right so they're trying to minimize the
difference between their expectation and
reality is that the free energy
notion right so um
so sculpting expectations at the front
end is what education is an experience
right and so with you know and when we
can
you know our system is
our educational system the united states
is set up for after the
based on the prussian school system
right that's the
um the de-schooling society book by um
ilitch so where our expectation is
industrial workers well now we don't
have industrial workers only we have
service workers and so our educational
system is not serving our
folks for instance right so we have
these
um the those influences it's
the the i guess the the thing that's
the thing i keep coming back to it's
like a situated cognition
that we situate our cognition and
externalities well
those externalities also have our
entities that have markov blankets you
know right now we're
thinking together right this is like
plato you said you know dialogue lets us
query consciousness so we're doing that
um and each of us
has our own view on on the direction of
this thing
right but they're so we're not
interacting with static things
we're interacting with dynamic things
that have their own dynamics and the
recruitment of those populations
is i think a lot of what happens in
legal concepts it's what's it's what
right now
i think this this the things we're doing
right now could make a big
impact on ethics discussions
because ethics anything that's not
written down in law
but is bad is now called an ethical
problem
right it's just the ethics is carrying a
lot of water right now for anxieties of
people generally
with the technologies and exponential
increase in everything
so it feels like we have an opportunity
for intervention because there is a
vacuum
of meaning in the current institutions
and it feels like this kind of
explanation might be a nice way to get a
toehold there
let me build on that scott so there was
a book i read called legal systems very
different from our own
by a fellow with the last name of
friedman but it is not myself or a
relative
directly and it really does a great job
of capturing
how different legal systems from uh
informal like criminal or prison legal
systems
justice systems using the term quite
broadly to different world
traditions very very different processes
that they followed but also they had
different
ends in mind now the current operating
environment
not just are we being confronted with
different uh interfaces mixing that
hadn't
combined before but also there's new
challenges
and so that's sort of like there was a
you know a two-stroke engine and a
two-stroke engine and a two-stroke
engine and they all were kind of coupled
in a way where they all were working
internally and now they're being cobbled
together and there's a lot of heat
informationally so to speak there's a
lot of parts that can burn
because there's so much heat being
wasted with the interfaces
and so can three two-stroke engines be
simply rewired into a six-stroke engine
well no it doesn't really work that way
how can you link those engines together
into a system and that's really the
question where
we're um addressing here is narratively
linguistically
memetically but just formally as well
how will these different systems
get cobbled together so that we're
actually connecting
the gasoline to the car moving in
forward one direction and in one piece
not taking gasoline and making something
that's just combustible
but only hurting people yep this is this
is where i
suggested people read flatland
because it's the adding of dimensions
right you add the mr sphere comes in and
lifts mr
square up and he can see through you can
untie a knot
in the upper dimension without crossing
the
not the rope right so in law
what we do is you create a new dimension
so
there was a time when we didn't have
credit cards and people used to do run
ious
at the bar and things like that it just
didn't exist
and so credit cards now serve this huge
function they de-risk huge swaths of
interactions right but
at one point they just didn't exist and
this guy d hawk wrote a book called
the k birth of the chaotic age and it's
kind of a crappy book but it's kind of
an interesting notion
the banks were like no no no no we don't
want your credit cards go away get out
of here with a paradigm shift
and then eventually they got the credit
cards got in and now try taking the
credit card fees away from the banks
right so what was impossible becomes
inevitable
and it feels like because things are so
stuck
this kind of approach that we're talking
about when
taken in markets and institutions is
going to that extra dimension
of credit cards or swaps frees up it
allows for these
interactions to take place just like the
extra dimension
in flatland allowed for mr square to get
new perspectives on
his life in his existence so it's it's a
really
it's a fundamentally different and
that's why they it's so interesting
the mark of blanket nesting
gets really interesting what which marco
blanket can nest within another one
and when you have communities of
interest one of the things i always
remind people of in new york for
instance you have little italy
you have a chinatown you have different
areas where people go together because
they're markov blankets their
language is easier it's easier to
communicate lowers the cost of
communication lowers the risk
you also have the jewelry district the
the flower district and the
cookware district economically people
cluster together so communities of
interest
they're co-locating well here if we look
at your diagram with the four
states you know the two states on the
left who sits right everyone is
now accumulating going to communities of
interest based on
the dynamics or rigidity of that left
hand
two states you know oh do you share a
risk do you share a
solution but what if we could have
communities of interest accumulated
based on their
capacity for change instead or something
like that
just to raise one really important piece
then stephen is
when people align around on the left
side of that figure
reducing risk or shared policy or shared
culture
it's often a similarity clustering okay
so people
often cluster based upon similar needs
similar understanding of the world
similar affordances
but let's imagine um the reality of the
organism
which is that actually it's a clustering
on the opposite in some senses of
disjoint abilities so in this context of
the body
if you said well there's one kind of
cell it can't move it just holds a bunch
of fat and it literally just
does hormone and fat processing and
there's another kind of cell
that will just dry out in a second in
the sun but it can contract
once and there's this other kind of and
it's like you'd say
they're not going to live in the same
neighborhood together it's like oh wait
no they do
that's the body and so how are we going
to
interpret this all the levels of what it
means to be a person economically and
culturally
and psychologically and understand that
it's neither
simple affinity nor simple dis affinity
on any scale
that will lead to function because
function and islands of function are
rare
in the almost unimaginably large state
space of
possible legal codexes or possible
programmings
that could be done or possible
personalities it's like there's more
ways to fail
for far from equilibrium systems and
selection is the hand that just keeps on
sweeping the ones that aren't working
off the table
so if we don't want to get swept off the
table we're going to be working together
that means coming together across our
differences so that we can have these
non-linear
successes as larger systems not the
largest
system it's not a simple imperative but
at the largest level that accomplishes
our mission
such as such interesting topics stephen
yeah and this well just like you were
just saying that about
these different cultures and the niche
construction i think this can help
there's a lot of problems in terms of
discourse around this
not more broadly in the world and i've
like when we talk about systems out
there in
like cities but then well how much is a
system and how much has been an evolving
niche construction some of which is
constructed
in this kind of linear you know this
kind of teleological
strategic way from above and and
geographical wave
and um but also some of it's just
because that's the way it's evolved over
time with some of this like we say these
dynamics
i think haven't really been brought in
or if they are brought in that kind of
ends up in the arts and it
it all gets framed in whichever metaphor
a particular
sort of school is applying that you can
get trapped by that
and i think this this actually came up
for me today so just like you're talking
about the indigenous
um ways you could have a governance or
other ways
is i think that we we have this idea of
systems
and these different systems and how do
we integrate them and there's this
assumption that they we need to be
integrating them but
like these indigenous systems you know
it flips from one to the other so for
instance
we have our western system which seems
to be like and we need to attack our
system is quite a sort of a progressive
leftist
approach or we need to all revert to
some sort of native
indigenous system and they had it right
and the body knows everything and if we
just listen to our body and there's this
kind of
gap whereby how do you find a way which
is kind of
maybe configuring different approaches
so it's like okay well where
can we configure the
other ways of knowing the other ways of
governing other ways of
and it's not just a case of like mash
them together because they may just have
a completely different dynamical
process and then they don't integrate
they just do different things at
different times like
cells do in the body
of course it's all gonna come down to
the details so
you know none of these metaphors or um
you know
questions are even the beginnings of the
answer
but yes that's definitely where we want
to be understanding
at that level of societies is
how much formal integration will there
be now if somebody says i have
i design the interface for different
operations
that is still coming from a cultural
context so the challenge
and part of the quest will be to frame
that interface in a way that doesn't
pretend that it has the neutral arbiter
ability
because that's actually one of those
universalist fallacies that were fallen
into
by abstractionists now we want to be
grounded in action and still talk about
an interface for action
and so i think actually that's why the
task may be
easier than the thought bringing
together
could be the action bringing together
i'm always reminded of scott's example
they told me a long time ago
with two lumber yards that are competing
in the market for selling lumber
but then they have the same insurance
and then i was like wait they also have
some internet provider
and they could pay taxes the same local
government and they could have the same
lunch service it's like everything
except for
lumber so it's like how many fronts they
might even share
a fence they so many areas
so they're almost collaborative on more
fronts than not
and so how do we take this understanding
that on overwhelming
number of our edges and even for each
edge on most of the domains
there's just massive areas where we're
in
alignment and then risk can be
catastrophic so it's like if we just
reduce
the amount of cascading failures in the
system
by playing to our strengths in the areas
where we are aligned
maybe all of a sudden now the lumber
yard people it's like oh you like this
kind of wood i like this kind of wood we
should just
niche partition but we're not going to
go niche partition and fork and never
talk
if you're going to be selling the luxury
and i'm going to be selling the consumer
wood
we need to have a better communication
interface oh you have employees who
speak this language
and i have employees who speak this
language well let's make an agreement
that we're going to send numbers back
and forth in this file type
on these dates and here's who we're
going to go to if that doesn't work
it's like wow these two companies were
fighting on the market
in a previous or a different paradigm
they might have you know
been wasting money on advertising or
committing different
sort of gray zone interferences with
each other's operation
but just by reframing it in this
multi-scale system
even if you're not doing a government
change whatever government system there
is
those two lumber yards now have a new
way of talking
to each other to their employees with
their lawyers
whatever potentially in a way that could
lead towards them working together
better
so that's just very powerful i think
that's what will be cool to continue
returning to
and and we're moving there really from a
zero-sum
game to a non-zero sum game
right there's a winner in loser and what
you do that's why you add i always think
of that you add the dimensionality
and it re casts the game as not a
winning
losing game and that's what we have to
do in gaia theory
right if you want to save the world from
from us
we have to recast the game as the as the
entire game
right this is the sustainable
development goals even the u.n has them
they're even tripping over them because
they have some they had one power plant
they developed the gujarat power plant
in bangladesh
and they scored big score on energy sdg
and on development sdg and then they got
sued by the local fishermen and the
local population for pollution which
would screw them on the other sdg
they didn't even talk among the sdgs at
the u.n now that's not surprising if you
know the u.n and the institution
but it shows you that it's even it's
hard to integrate even when you have the
the same
source of the norms or the or the
aspirations
they just go for it on one of them and
they don't they're not talking to each
other
right and here's why preventing failure
is so critical
um which body is healthier each organ
system at 90 percent function
or most of them at 99 and one is at zero
well yep that body is dead so all of the
functions need to be adequate
or better and we need to improve
adequate improve resiliency
improve accessibility etc but preventing
failure
uh cannot be uh just
part of the discussion on reducing risk
reducing cascading failure
has to be an imperative and so in that
framework where we want multiple
components to be functioning
it just reframes the oh should the
government be interfering here or should
this person be undertaking this policy
and again like i said like the task to
synchronize on action might be easier
than thought
so those two lumber yards getting them
to go to the same
religious institution or send their
children the same education or listening
to the same youtube channels
why why even go down that road
in the metaphor when you could just
offer them a service
where they're de-risking their lumber
business
so instead of saying we'll synchronize
these lumber yard people on
this and then they'll just act nicely
together it's like
yeah or you could just provide the
interface so that whoever they are
however things change they'll be able to
play nicely together
instead of just saying well if we
synchronize them in this way
then they'll know what to do they won't
because people don't well
and that's why one of the things that i
talk to people about as i say
our recruitment that i'm doing in the
program at the lab
is not based on selflessness it's based
on self-interest
and the assertion is that they can
de-risk in ways they cannot do
unilaterally period
that's what i tell people and so you get
together so it's a commitment if they
want to de-risk in these new ways they
can't do it by themselves just like a
stoplight
i can't i didn't send out around a memo
saying let's all stop at the red light
that was done
right these are these are scales that we
can't do unilaterally
and so that tempting that bait of saying
you can go over there and
like with swaps australia swaps were
outlawed when they first came out and
the banks in australia were getting
killed
because they couldn't swap out their
interest rate risk so they lobbied the
australian government
to allow for swaps and then they did
allow for swaps and they were
able to swap out their interest rate
risk like other banks
the downside is they all then got hurt
in 2008 when the swaps were used for
speculative purposes that's a different
problem
but that invitation
to de-risk in ways you can't do alone
it's kind of it's that it's a crass
way of getting people in the space but
to me it's the hook that joins that
left-hand side and the right-hand side
with those four spheres
because you right on the left-hand side
you have this characterization of risk
as a zero-sum game
on the right-hand side well maybe it's
not a zero-sum non-zero sum in that
context but it allows for a bigger
the dimensionality of de-risking
increases when you increase the system
size and so if you get those people who
are similarly situated together
it's new markets that's what trade
associations are
right trade associations people are
competing all the potato chips
lumber it doesn't matter trade
association competitors get together
and what do they do share information
and insurance those are the two big
things they co-insure for some whatever
risk they share
unless they can buy insurance cheaper
whatever kind
and they uh and they also share
information so they can
understand situational awareness better
yep
i put up the slide here again um
yeah yvonne do you have anything you
want to
add or remark on no just chilling yeah
okay continue scott
wait weirdly i think we just lost
scott's audio
in between oh no okay okay sorry
continue
uh but i was thinking i there was some
other thing i was going to say but i
can't remember
now about that oh yes yes there's an
example from the fisheries industry
so much this eleanor ostrom um worked
very closely with people in the
fisheries so a lot of fisheries
are designed with ostrom notions and um
so uh the of the commons and one of the
things that a friend of mine who works
in the um uh hold on a second
okay stephen any okay sorry one of the
guys
sorry one of the guys who works in the
um fishing industry he said
they had a problem they have this thing
called bycatch and it's the fish you're
not supposed to catch
so let's say i'm going to make up these
numbers in this species but let's say
you're allowed to catch 200 000 pounds
of flounder
but they would orange rock fish or
yellow rock fish and if you catch four
pounds of that
you have to stop fishing it's a
protected species
you can't fish anymore you can't pay
your bills you can't
buy the oil you can't send your kids to
school you don't have money
so what they did they were trying to
figure out how we're going to protect
this
orange rock fish the yellow rock fish so
what they did is they said okay let's
pool the allocations
of different fisheries so if they had
three guys
each had a four pound allocation so they
can pool it and make a 12-pound
allocation
so they can then what happens is if one
of the one of the people
goes out and fishes and catches five
pounds of yellow rock fish
he can still fish whereas he might in
the past have had to stop
so he spread the risk out but then what
happens is the other fishermen
start to be policemen because they're
cutting it to their allocation
so they go over and they say hey hey use
a different size net or don't fish in
that area whatever they share
information because he's cutting in it's
an economic loss for all of them because
they pulled their allocation
so to me that's a big deal that that
that
idea because what they're doing is
they're spreading risk
and when you spread risk it's like
insurance if more people have claims out
there
and my premiums go up right so i'm going
to
encourage things that make things safer
right as a stakeholder in that system
and so similarly here
it feels like when you move to that
right side diagram
we're going to have more avenues with
which to
create information flows among the
parties
that will actually de-risk better than
the left side and make it cheaper
stephen and then i'll have a point on
that
yeah i think this this use of this
diagram could be important because
yeah the in a way i suppose this diagram
on the left it's like you either just
put in laws
or to mitigate those risks and
challenges
or the transdisciplinary tool that we
have at our disposal
is money money is the thing that
everyone uses basically is the
transdisciplinary
allocation of what to do on projects and
it doesn't it it's probably highly
problematic and there's not
really a lot of other things apart from
what budget gets allocated that allows
that so
is there a way that this can provide
us and and at different scales because
sometimes yes
it's fairly clean at kind of a national
level or
you know your rulers level and the
individual but
most stuffs happening in between as
we're talking about
how can we somehow get a handle which is
not too culturally
or metaphorically uh constructed but is
is is is maybe relatively universal i
know it's bad to use that term
but i think there's something in that in
in in being able to say okay this is how
this information gains happen happening
this is how this you know and now you're
starting to have a way to
talk about um dynamics
um in ways which aren't normally
possible
yeah one thought on that and again to
this point about
you want to design the nexus the
interface in a way that
is inclusive and accessible but respects
that not
just do people disagree but they have
actually different visions and
understandings about this whole
system that we're in and so here's and
then
where we can tie it to this figure and
how it could be used to communicate and
maybe even organize around
so on the left side it leads towards
abstraction
because it's like well let's let's wait
until we're
less um ambiguous and then once you have
no ambiguity it's like well let's figure
out what the least risky policy is
but guess what all the policies have
risks and even if there was one that
somehow had less risk than
strictly all the others there's still
black swan events and there's still
people with different
preferences for a given pipeline for oil
or for a given fishing agreement
so the idea that you're going to
minimize risk for all parties in a way
that they're satisfied with
is going to be this quest that you're
going to be at the the drawing board
quite probably forever let's contrast
that with the right side
and you know the the authors i hope will
be okay with us taking wide latitude
because
you know we're taking this figure beyond
what yep it's frame but that's what's
fun right
yeah now let's go to that drawing board
with uh um the power plant and the
fishers and the ostrom and everything
like that
instead of just getting froze to the
drawing board left so now we're on the
right side
and we're saying look we are at the
drawing board so whether we're speaking
through a translator or you believe that
we have different interests
we're here at the nexus so universal
aside what's locally going to be working
for our system
well we have two imperatives we want to
make maximum information gain but we
want to maximize if you look at that iso
given p it's not information gain on
the observations that's this part see
how it's strictly in the o
here's ambiguity about state
observations okay
this is maximizing information gain on
states and observations given policy
in other words we're not just reducing
our ambiguity
about states the world like give me a
more accurate stock ticker
this is like hey what's the most
informative
uh policy that we can enact to learn
about the states
so we want to query the markets in a way
that isn't just getting increased
precision on viewing them
and so now we're all at the table
together so whether we believe ourselves
to have or actually have adversarial
interest in one dimension of 300 or
all the dimensions or whatever we have
an expansive
maximization growth-oriented goal
together
which is implementing policy that helps
us
understand our system and the mapping
between the hidden states
and the observations better together now
by doing that we're also engaging in
joint action
which will prepare us for larger and
better action
and what are we doing joint action to do
well
part of it is to be consistent with the
kind of system who we believe ourselves
to be
but the other part the minimization what
we're running away from the stick
is disorder with respect to the
observations
so not with respect to us getting
paralyzed about which policy
but we want to reduce our surprise about
our observations
in the context of optimal policy okay so
here how much co2 is there really in the
world and how much do we really make and
what would be the riskiest policy and
should we just remove gas cars and i
mean you could go down this rabbit hole
forever right
here is here's a predicted trajectory
here's different types of models and
what they predict about the trajectory
of co2 levels through time
and we want to reduce our uncertainty
about that model
together all kinds of people who believe
different things we're going to reduce
our uncertainty
purely about observations as
we jointly use policy together
to learn more it's just such a positive
way of framing it
and again people are still going to
disagree but we're
coming to the table together so as long
as we're not at arms and we're coming to
the table together
we don't need to go universal we don't
need to go culture free
we just say we're here we're figuring
this out today
for ourselves now and for other people
later
and when you that's beautiful i mean i
you you
i can't wait till i have more facility
with the concepts because
what you're describing the processes
you're describing
are going to become governance it's not
like we're going to find governance of
the processes
those processes will be governance
that's going to how it's going to happen
and so it's a very the question is you
know we're on the left side how do we
get to the right side right what are the
stages
that we can do to move us over there how
do we
provide prepare ourselves as groups to
be able to function on the right side
in a natural organic kind of way one of
the things that i've been advocating for
is collecting practices from the left
side
but then having groups stare at the
practices
so you can say okay let's it's basically
making different
changing the assembly right the
disintermediation
of the left side has been done by the
internet it's done by covid
it's done by the big challenges to those
systems they reveal the limitations of
those systems
and so the distance remediation is done
on the right side we're going to
re-intermediate
because there is still mediation of the
individual
components in the system right they're
brought together but we're
reintermediating with a fundamentally
it's it's fundamentally different in
some ways in some ways it's quite
similar
and so one of the things that i'm
interested in is trying to find ways to
make it so similar that people don't
even realize you know they or
or they're comfortable with the move to
this new
framing of analysis very cool yeah
stephen
and this this ties in as well actually
this is so good that you've gone through
this diagram so it makes it very much
jump out but this like the safe to fail
approach of of trying to so if you
imagine that policy
will the red wheel on the on the right
hand side
you know active inference knows that
that's really our choices
are what we do with our policy we
a lot of what's out there in the world
the hidden states you know we only have
so much control over
so if we're able to almost
shift the policies in there and
and knowing that they're safe to shift
so these safe to fail
experiments which is what they talk
about with so if you do safe to fail
policies which means that you can then
observe the states observe what
observations observe the overlaps
observe the dynamics over time
then you've got an awful lot of um
new information that you can use and
obviously the key is to do
not to have something in there which
will be um
there's this anti-fragile comes into
that as well you know
so you can learn as you do and and
obviously knowing that
there will be certain times when you've
got to pull away and
stick to a you know risk minimization
focus but
this you know it gives a way to talk
about that
probably to people from very different
views of the world
yep so another metaphor there with
performance would be like a martial art
and the safe to fail and the sparring
and the play
so there's times to play and you know
for children and there's times to be
serious but no matter what you're doing
it's always serious because people can
fall
if you're walking you can fall if you're
talking you can say something mean
if you're you know holding data you can
lose the data so everything is very
important
and so we need to have that resilience
in mind
one other way in which this can be used
so this is um
putting a little bit beside this uh
purely
like somebody at the table who doesn't
want to communicate with us
scenario so now we're in a situation
where like people want to work together
at least they've bought on to that level
okay
we're talking about the system and
someone just has this figure up you know
just as they do
and steven you said it like what we
control is policy we control
climate policy you know what we don't
control the climate but what do we
control
our climate policy we don't control
biogeochemical cycles we influence them
but we don't control the outcome and so
people could be talking
and someone's like well i want to see
this okay you're talking about c you're
talking about your preference
vector and someone said or are we
talking about the state of the world are
you actually saying that this is how
people feel or are you just stating your
preferences about the world because it's
fine if you want to you know i i want to
learn about your preferences
and remember your preferences are the
key factor
that really go into our policy but our
policy
is not the same thing as the states
about the world yeah so it's like okay
now what are the observations some says
no no actually it's 80 percent
so okay your inference is that this is
is that right well here's this
observation oh well this study is biased
okay
well great let's you know what if it was
a factor of two so there's so many ways
just to have this figure up
and someone says are you sure about that
policy selection
say okay well it sounds like we're up
here sounds like we're in the
metacognitive world we're thinking
implicitly about our own group's
generative model
of this policy decision making process
and it seems like you're uncertain about
this
and what are you uncertain about okay
what could we figure what could we
reduce uncertainty about
is it your preferences is it the way
that your preferences and our
uncertainty
are being combined with the affordances
and the niche
into policy that of course is the
hardest not to untie that's control
theory and everything
but you can at least say hey is it your
uncertainty is it your preferences
is it the niche perception affordances
not just the preferences but the niche
itself e the prior
and is that being combined in a way that
makes sense to generate policy
because if you disagree with the policy
which part of these was it because
that's all that went into it
so don't just say you disagree with the
policy tell me do you want something to
be
do you value something that wasn't
valued by this policy
okay now that we're talking about a
given policy do we have synchronization
at least coarsely on the starting state
not on all the details but at least like
the starting state for our scenario
and are we talking about states the
world do you believe that our policy
is going to influence the b you think
that the cutting the miles per gallon to
20 is gonna change the way that the
hidden state
co2 in the world changes through time
you think it's gonna do that
well i don't think it's gonna do that or
i you know think it's gonna do this
instead
and so now we have an interface okay
policy is how
states of the world are changing not
just as a function of models
of prediction but as a function of our
interference in the system
and it's going to be manifested in
observables not just we believe that 80
of this will be happening by this future
time but rather
as a function of policy we're going to
see these observables and if we're
surprised by the observables we see
along the way
we're going to be course correcting and
we're going to be at the same table
again so there's so many actual
structural ways to talk about this i
think and as well as narratively
that people could even having this up
maybe it could be simpler than this one
maybe kind of a few more pieces
but just separating out where people
disagree it's like
yeah in a legal i don't know yeah in a
legal system i could imagine this being
useful too
oh it would have to be recast as
something that people wouldn't you know
fall out of the chair because legal
people don't like to see
squiggly latin and greek symbols but
but the but the absolutely no question
the way you described it what you're
doing is you're really mapping
i mean it's teaching and you're and and
and showing people you know whenever you
have a map that says you are here
you know when you're lost in the zoo or
something like that and really it's a
you are here map
right so cge you know it's and it's
allowing more granularity
and it's offering more dimensionality
for solutions right because if people
are just talking about policy
they'll be ambiguity if they're not
talking about c g or e
yes yeah what are your preferences see
what are the field of affordances e
and the prior over those like the quote
nuclear option
it's an affordance and it's the last
resort
so tied up in the affordance is how
likely it is that's your prior over
policies
so you have the field of affordances and
the prior about them
and then you have your preferences c i
want to see a world where there isn't
radioactive fallout and then you have
your uncertainty
and then those get combined in a way
that is formalized with g and that
relates to
pi policy selection being the outcome of
the free energy
being minimized which is again what's
the most likely policy
and someone's like wait most likely it's
like right but most likely
under the model of the world that you
believe will happen
not just the one that you think is like
the run of the mill because quote the
run of the mill is not run-of-the-mill
yeah it's really interesting because i
mean you're integrating subjectivity
into an analysis of the reality
in a formal way it
has that i believe that this is where
the dual instrumentalism is the most
powerful thing
in the fep zone so the dual
instrumentalism
again it's like there's it's also kind
of like a bailey and mott
i don't know if that's being
mispronounced but like where there's a
strong and a weak form of an argument
so again the strong claim would be this
is what systems are and this is how
they're
um operating that is what a bacteria is
that is what the markov blanket is
but the actual beaker claim is just
we're going to use it as an instrument
it's like yeah we use linear aggressions
to mod in time series modeling
to model gdp through time or regression
of you know
height versus risk for some disease it's
like it didn't say
people are linear regressions by doing
that it did lead to a world in which
certain types of conclusions were
reached
but it wasn't that people were linear
models it was actually consequences
so this is just a different statistical
model and as we're
exploring today and we'll continue to
explore even qualitatively it helps
structure
messy discussions about adversarial
relationships
and in that way which we're only barely
scratching the surface of like you know
really formalizing the markov blankets
around companies and things like that
having this type of a structuring and
being able to be uh disambiguous
but it could be so much more it could be
translated between languages
it could be diversions it could have
impartial
um you know trust providing uh groups
there's so much that could be done there
and it's funny because
so one of the books i have on the shelf
here is uh by hannemann it's called
doing money
and it's about how money is a universal
risk consolidator
so you know you get money and you can
take care of your other risks basically
so one of the things i've been wondering
about is well money's kind of turned
into data because you don't really spend
cash anymore
so why can't data itself without being
monetized be a universal risk
um mitigator
stephen you cracked me up when you said
that money was transdisciplinary
i've never heard you know people say
that trans discipline research but never
it's so true though the departments will
pay each other and money
they won't cite each other but they'll
pay each other so it's so true
and so and so that but data can data now
be and can this system
because money we you go to an airport
you got to convert one system into
another so there's different
encoding of the bills themselves right
okay so that's
but but ultimately i always tell people
if i walk out of if i'm outside a
courthouse and someone says i just got a
ten thousand dollar judgment
i don't know if it's for a divorce case
a slip and fall i mean it's money it's
ten thousand dollars is identical
you can buy the same amount of groceries
but it could be for various different
things that you were
you were compensated right so in
data it feels like this model might
allow us to have
data be a medium of exchange
and maybe storage i don't know i won't
go into that right now
but immediate exchange of risk without
having to go through the monetary
loop very
very interesting yep i can
kind of imagine some areas stephen
and this this might be where bringing
the body back in can help too
as we you know you talk about like
there's there's money in my hand
there's there's money that we talk about
when you get it or something and then
there's capital
which is almost like an augmented um
cognition process which is up there in
the markets you know that we've
offloaded onto
and is very hard to embody
what's going on up there yeah it's it's
like it goes off
it does its calculation it comes back
and we do what
i mean half the people doing are doing
on screens who themselves are being
proxies for other people you know so
there's
there's there's a question about um
where this comes back into
ultimate um sense making at different
time scales yep
yep yeah ivan was smiling before i
did were you smiling at the money thing
let's let's maybe have yeah
let's have uh anything you want to go
there yvonne if you want otherwise let's
have a little
closing just imagine you and you and
your money
and your money of new people
yep so maybe we'll have a final set of
thoughts so prepare
that but the other side um scott of the
the money uh trading in the airport
is that uh in a healthy system
every sale is bi-directionally
consensual every agreement is not
feeling
forced it's like so somebody wanted your
peso the other person wanted the yen so
they made a deal they met in a
marketplace
they wouldn't have found it on
craigslist the operating cost would have
been too high but
somebody wanted it now when does it
become deranged
well when there's um extra market forces
that force people to do
things or when there's you know
devaluation
market manipulation etc etc but again
it's not like there's a pure
untrammeled market out there and then
it's like oh regulation how dare they
it's actually we construct the market
it's like we're building the bowl
so it's not just like there's a pure
bowl and then you've defined it by
putting clay on it it's like
no what is the structure that you're
going to be
interfacing in and can that not just be
imbued
with our values which aren't going to
always have justification they're often
asthmatic
but can actually allow diverse agents
to act according to their deeply held
axioms
so that there is ability of people who
have different faith
in different things yeah and it's been a
joke for so long oh you don't need to
believe in the legitimacy of the
government to use the currency if a fiat
and now we're just seeing it in a new
light
so it's real it's really interesting the
market may be
just an emergence from the fact of
information seeking in trades
yep and also leveraging and how that's
trust like there's bitcoin on the
blockchain
just these are the examples i think
about um yep but
then there's the 10x leveraged bitcoin
who legitimized
that exchange or that person to um
offer a 10x leverage or some other type
of asset based upon
leveraged on bitcoin nobody gave that
permission if that person or that
operation is reputable
um and to whatever extent it is it will
succeed or hopefully
and again anything other than that is
dysfunction so
there's a way to talk about that in a
way that is pretty
different from the reward optimization
of different competing agents
that's previous paradigm reward
optimization competitive agents
and we're not just moving from
competitive to cooperative
it's actually not that simple it's
actually more about
from the uh reward to the precision
guiding mindset and that everything else
falls in line after that
and the action and the precision are the
key pieces
some of the keys and so that's the
coherence
lending factor yes we want to be precise
about process
together that's the minimal meme not
we're going to have abundance in the
future but
today we're going to have precision here
yep so it's really yeah
it's a it's a different it's really
fascinating the way it's going to
iterate itself into
it's more scalable but it's not yet
scaled
yeah you know i think of it makes me
think of adaptation studies i have a
book on cambridge uh book
adaptation studies in theater where if
you take romeo and juliet you translate
it into another language
you got a lot of work to do because
there's a lot of phrasing
and there's a lot of behavior a lot of
things for adaptation
what we're doing here is it's just like
a giant simultaneous adaptation
vehicle right because everyone's coming
in with priors
and this system allows people to
discover things that they have in common
it allows them to act in common
and that's going to have such huge power
it won't and it won't be something that
will create spaces for it it will create
the space
this the interaction space will
evolve and then be and then it'll be
parameterized in metrics and you'll know
if you're in it or not there'll be
certain behaviors
that indicate you're in it right but
it's it's that's why i always say the
process becomes the governance
it's not you don't that's a lot of
people there's the ai problem right now
not our ai but the artificial
intelligence
that everyone is trying to create
everyone that i can find is trying to
create systems
to govern the people creating the ai but
not the ai system itself
and i'm thinking more along the lines of
asimov which is you need the rules for
the robots themselves
similarly here each one of these systems
is a robot
it's not program bias per se but it's
caused by us
and it has features that are
the result of our desires and needs so
it's programmed in that way
corporations are robots i think they're
programs part of our constructed niche
is how we would consider it it you're
never going to break away
it's intertwined with us it's in our
niche yep right
right and so the so it's interesting
because i think a lot of
folks look at authority
like the fiat money is i think the u.s
is a fiat not just because of rule of
law but because of a monopoly of
violence
we have the most guns and bombs
and so that it's a violent it's violence
and imperialism and all that stuff
that's wrapped up in
fiat right there's a power there and i
think the power is shifting from
physical violence to other forms of
information
and we use the word violence here but
information authority and it feels like
the ability of this system to declare
that it can get you closer to reality
continuously it's dynamically
it's like the scientific method it's
dynamically re-jiggering itself
i wouldn't say closer to truth i would
say towards a better process together
yes dynamically right yep that's right
there's no there is no end state of
truth yep
but that value proposition is not
characteristic of the current systems
and so
it has a unique feature of the de-risks
in a way that's much
more effective than the current systems
it requires people to do the cooperative
thing
which is like i said with credit cards
or atms or
swaps or anything with mitochondria
right you know your free existing things
have to come together because there's a
better deal to be had right
so that's and so that so the convey are
conveying why there's a better deal to
be had
we can use the existing problems in the
world climate change
war it's not even a better deal
it's a better negotiating table yes and
that's that's right that's
always the reframe is always from yes
there will be better
states to we're gonna seek precision
today
yes beautiful beautiful and that gets
back to that
now versus past and future thing that i
was struggling with before
right we're not gonna we're not saying
it's better it's it's a better way
to be and we don't know where being
takes us because that's we have models
of it you have a model i have a model we
have a model let's get together
figure out where we want to be the
reality is the common
synthesis of those desires i guess
as evolving through time closing closing
statement from first stephen then yvonne
if he wants
then back to scott well yeah i suppose
the takeaway um and there was
you had the e the g what was the third
letter again there was a
c is the preference okay let's see i
think that's really useful i think
that's like a
nice meeting point there between and i
keep coming back to this but the
ergodicity and non-ergodicity
in the sense that you know as you get
down to the smaller scale
the body and i think even when you get
into this outside of cognition
everything's got to follow that growth
kind of ergotic kind of
churn and then you start to have this
ability to bring in these non-ergodics
as we get to larger time scales and you
know
we even see as we get now to the state
and how
you can borrow money in ways which an
individual can't we've seen this with
the eu
because they're not constrained by
lifespan in the way that mortgage
mortgages are so you've got this weird
ability to bring in preferences in that
um about of non-ergodic sort of ways of
just making a choice and creating
deliberately steady state like a fiat
currency the whole point is it's steady
and non-ergodic but we actually and this
is where i think a lot
of the work with the indigenous cultures
is they are they could say they're
trapped in the old
cyclical way of understanding the world
but actually
that gives you a way to tune into your
deeper existential way of knowing
about the long-term future because that
is
where your phenotype knowledge comes
from
not um you know the okay off we have
these structures that
give us this ability to also do deep
temple
depth but we do lose the ability to
integrate
free energy in such a new york the
dimensions come down and down and down
and down to these kind of
artifacts so yeah this is anyway this is
what
is coming up for me thanks well i hope
steven that you and others
can in the future you know listen back
to what you've laid out
and hopefully see it in a broader
perspective
what you were hinting at yvonne any
closing thoughts for 2020
indeed yeah sure i just want to uh
thank you all for brilliant discussion
and it's
the great discussion for the enter of
this
strange year i hope to see you all
next next from the beginning from the
january
and thanks for your help in the project
from the beginning really
critical yeah so very chill scott
closing thought you guys are this is
this is beautiful you guys are beautiful
this is awesome i'm i feel like a
metamorphosis i'm i'm i'm going to
pupate a little bit
and then i'm going to come out after the
new years and be ready to fly with you
guys this is
this is really delightful and
fascinating
and i think it's going to be really um
very helpful to a lot of problems that
are out there in the world it feels like
there's a lot of
um solution space that gets opened up
with this
and in in introducing it in in
digestible chunks
so i always talk to my clients about
where are you now where do you want to
be that's a tough one and now i see why
it's a tough one because it's
in a way the wrong question
where do you where do we want to be
individually and then how do we
synthesize
and then what are the ways to get there
and then you triage them
so that's a standard thing i used to use
now that's changing because it's a
the exploration of where we want to be
is the answer to that really hard second
question which is
people have difficulty answering so
thank you for inviting me on the journey
this is great stuff
so to close um on that um
scott you just you laid out a helpful
way of thinking about it with just where
do you want to go this is common goal
setting who are we where do we want to
go
how are we going to get there but you
brought in two pieces which is the
values
the values are what is not explicitly
described but they're part of the
preference and the policy
and so combining all of these disparate
threads together
and not having one heat engine for the
refrigerator and one power plant for the
other one
but combining all of these threads
together so we can have a discussion
from multi-perspective so that's the
intercultural component
multi-perspective but also bringing
together
these co-excellent values that we have
for system function
exploration so many other features but
really um my closing
thought is for this live stream that
uh tomorrow probably i'm gonna record a
video called 12.0 that is going to be
the clock striking midnight
on 2020 and then we will indeed head
into a very exciting 2021
and beyond so uh both of you
uh well actually all of you i guess are
uh rsvp'd for the active inference lab
so i'm just really looking forward to
those three projects
and just like you said scott with the
digestible bits live
livestream has been our learning process
we've all learned so much along
this journey but now we also want to be
thinking about could make shorter
content ones that have interactive parts
who knows but there's going to be yeah
great things
happening ahead so thanks everyone who's
listening live
or in replay thanks guys for
participating fantastic and and happy
new year to everybody
wow what a discussion what a discussion
all right well i'm going to terminate
the live stream
so thanks everyone and i will talk to
you later